foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much for coming to start a
World Cup well everybody here I think
well most people have seen you on Shark
Tank and they know you're into
Investments but I want to start with how
did you become an investor what got you
into the investment space
you know what what happens I think in
your transition from being an operator
uh to an investor is you go through the
experience of trying to determine you
have the executional skills to operate a
business and then if if you're
successful you take that knowledge more
importantly what the mistakes you made
and try and help others that you invest
in avoid those mistakes that makes you a
more uh successful investor so
that transition occurred after you know
a fuel liquidity events and like
everybody else I retired for a year and
I got bored out of my mind I've seen
every beach in the world and it's boring
and I wanted to get back in the game and
I came back
um in private equity and Venture and
I've worked for some of the larger firms
for a while and I said I can do this
myself and I found my own firm that's
generally the transitional path and uh
shark Tay came along which believe me
nobody thought this would happen
um and and they're we're going to learn
a little bit about Shark Tank today
because the secret sauce of Shark Tank
is customer acquisition uh you'll see uh
on tonight's show a product uh that's
going to air will sell two or three
million dollars worth of it in one hour
we'll not pay anything for customer
acquisition
um and my job as the investor is to take
advantage of this massive social media
platform and when I am when I invest in
companies and I don't want this to come
off as arrogant but it's a fact I'm not
like another investor
most investors come from you know
private Equity or Venture firms they're
great people they have zero ability to
acquire customers all they can do is pay
for them
my strategy is how can I tell your
company's story and help you acquire
customers at a significant lower cost
that's the model of what I do
great well as you mentioned you are
different from a lot of investors out
here and we do have a lot of
entrepreneurs here as well so I want to
focus a little bit on the entrepreneur's
side yeah you've heard thousands and
thousands of pitches by now
what makes a winning pitch in your
opinion how is that different from other
pitches that don't get the funding yeah
there's three attributes
um and the reason I have this data is
the show shark tank is on in 42
countries some it's the generic American
tape with you know voice over to the
language of that geography and others is
new productions like Canada and England
and Australia New Zealand Brazil and
Mexico where it's called Lion's Den in
Germany and dragon stand in Australia
whatever it's the same idea and it
doesn't matter what geography what
language the entrepreneurial Adventure
is the same so there was a little
research done about four years ago that
took the unedited tape from all the
pictures that actually got funded did
not determine the outcome of the
business they weren't looking for that
they were trying to figure out in the
period that you're engaging with the
investor
what were common attributes that
achieved success
so it turns out not in just some of the
cases one hundred percent of the cases
three attributes existed here they are
if it's the only thing you guys remember
from this this is it so you should write
these down because they'll serve you
well uh in the future and I actually I
consider these attributes the definition
of leadership in any sector because I
don't care if you're a preacher a
politician an entrepreneur a mother a
father
no one follows you if you don't know
where you're going so here are the three
issues number one can you articulate the
opportunity in 90 seconds or less
the whole idea of presenting an
opportunity is to Define it very quickly
what is it that you have that could be
such a great opportunity what idea is it
but if you can't explain it and most
most of the great pitches you can
explain in 30 seconds here's what I do
this is why you I'm here this is my
product this is my service so you only
get 90 seconds for that
now this is very important
great ideas this is number two great
ideas are a dime a dozen what's really
rare are executional skills so now you
have the ear of the investor you could
be in a VC pitch you could be in an
elevator you could be on Shark Tank
carpet whatever
okay I like the idea
why can you make it happen what is it
about you and your team that can execute
on this do you know the sector have you
done this before have you worked for a
competitor have you failed three times
to figure out the mistakes you made I
personally would rather invest in an
entrepreneur that's failed and felt the
sting of failure and it's highly
motivated to get out there and fix what
they did wrong because they've learned
from it but that doesn't matter what
matters is
to tie your executional skills to the
idea so that all of a sudden you're
mitigating risk for the investor great
idea great team
and I can feel the change in a room in
the context of Shark Tank
you can start to see all these sharks
and I say hey what do we got here yeah
and and because you you have to have
executional skills
but there's one more
and this one's the killer
I've seen this happen so many times so
let's put it back in the context of
Shark Tank you've beat out a hundred
thousand applications to be one of the
240 companies it tapes and you're there
you're you have your moment you got the
first one right everybody loves your
idea you got the second one right you
gives it convinced everybody that you're
the right person to execute
and then this happens
you have to know your numbers
how big is the market how fast is it
growing what's the gross margins what's
the break-even analysis how many
competitors do you have you have to have
those right on the tip of your tongue
because that is the glue that binds if
you get onto Shark Tank carpet and
you've got everybody that's in your deal
you don't know your numbers you deserve
to burn in hell in perpetuity and I will
personally put you there and I've done
it many times you have to know your
numbers it's the language of business
you get those three right the
probability of a deal goes up
geometrically higher and it's in every
single successful pitch you can go back
in time go and look at Shark Tank
episodes you will see all three of those
attributes every time someone gets
funded if you like that video where do
you see my next one don't forget to
click right over here and subscribe